[Music]
what does f
stand for an f boy um ferocious boy
ferocious boy
okay frightening boy ferrari boy yeah
these f boys yeah i'm boy
yeah fart boy who are the fart boys here
the 12 of these guys have admitted to
our producers that they're just here to
bust the ass
12 12 of the boys here have admitted to
our producers behind the scenes
that they're lactose intolerant yeah my
name is declan
um i'm from temecula california and
i [ __ ] love to fart yeah nice
i'm gonna hook up with so many girls
here and bust ass in their face and
blame it on the next guy
no i'ma hook up with so many girls bust
ass in their face and blame it on them
it's the smelliest villa of the summer
you want to see a gas lighter i'm a
gaslighter oh my god who farted in here
sounds like it was you wow that's good
that's good i didn't fart hey what i'm
just saying
yeah what about this for a gaslighter
little blue angel
huh well now that no one's here
this villa is about to get smelly
stinky and fired
up oh yo yo bring that torch over here
whoa don't let the girl see that one
yo who had taco bell
me i always have taco bell declan you're
crazy
it's f boy island this is in the
interview room
dude eating an entire block of cheese
winking at the camera
oh you wait july 29th it's gonna be
stinky today we're doing the
beans challenge
[Laughter]
it's all just they're spitting beans
into each other's mouths
farting first one to fart gets exposed
first one the fart gets gets the um
the private villa or like the the no no
they have to hide that they're a farter
okay so you know it's like so they're
going to do a bean challenge and they
got to make sure
no one knows so it's like today's going
to be hard
i've seen the beans and i already want
to rip one so i'm just going to have to
keep it to myself and
maybe i'll let off a little sbd but you
know yeah
okay so if you win the challenge then
you get the handicapped bathroom stall
like the only one
like the one that's private so that you
can fart in peace yeah you get it you
get a soundproof [ __ ]
yeah which is the the the sweet what's
the [ __ ] word of the world
hideaway it's the highway it's the
hideaway [ __ ] yeah
and she can never know if you're a [ __ ]
boy yeah if you know if you're a f boy
f boy yeah sorry
and there's three guys on there that
don't fart they've never farted in their
whole lives they're not built to fart
yep
oh yeah maybe they just haven't done it
yet they're fart versions um yo my name
is vito
i'm from jersey and i've never farted
never farted i've i've been in fights
i've been in threesomes but i've never
[ __ ] farted
farting is [ __ ] weird
fast forward to halfway through the
season i'm just here doing my [ __ ]
thing i'm here to find love
and here we are in the middle of the day
and she's saying
i fought it now i'm [ __ ] pissed i
think vinnie farted i didn't [ __ ]
fart
i'm not a [ __ ] f boy get get her out
of my face dude
i'm a [ __ ] snap i'm not a [ __ ] hey
don't talk to her like that dog hey [ __ ]
you man talk to her like that man you
shut her why don't you tell her how
you're a fart boy listen to him right
now
you just [ __ ] you are they came out
you just [ __ ] farted let me smell
your butt right spell his butt right now
let me smell your butt you can smell my
butt it smells like fart just as i
thought
just as i thought cuz another guy
no one knows
[Music]
i was watching tommy from the side when
he accused minnie
i saw a pocket of air come out of shorts
then they can they get another angle it
goes
yeah just yeah yeah
it goes to night time hey so i don't
want to get in the middle of anything
but
vinnie vito didn't fart it was tommy
here i am thinking i'm in love with
tommy
he's an f boy
oh my god you saw him fart swear to god
swear to god
i have to go tell the girls please
please don't bring this back to me let's
go see it on the infrared camera
it was giant it was it was tommy it was
tommy
dude at the [ __ ] then there's like
some weird game mechanism
where they can choose like they'll get
an ipad
to see [ __ ] on an infrared camera and
then that's castlemore
yeah yeah some more just a mexican
restaurant yeah yeah
you go to castlemore
welcome to casa cheese burrito yeah
and they get to fart it up like crazy
yeah oh
thank god we're here boys it's time to
[ __ ] go
they said there were 12 f boys on this
island it looks like it's all of us
[Music]
yo i just fought it for the first time
no i just [ __ ] no it
everyone's partying and then vinnie's at
the end of the table he's like
goes quiet yo vito just farted bro
i just [ __ ] farted i've never [ __ ]
farted in my whole life
he's got that like that drunk glaze over
us i've never [ __ ] fought it before
the girls get live video footage of them
having they're like they look like
they're having the time of their
lives god then it goes to i knew they
were all f boys and they're all farting
and they're all farting
no i can't believe it
and then season two is f girl island and
they find out if girls actually [ __ ]
no it's s girl [ __ ] girl ireland
[ __ ] my name's destiny i'm from
des moines iowa and i'm a [ __ ] girl
i'm a small town [ __ ] girl most girl
most girls are from a big city but i'm
different because i'm a small town [ __ ]
girl yeah i like horses
and hanging out with my family and
taking big steamy dumps
most of these girls [ __ ] in a beautiful
bathroom with marble floors or tile i'll
[ __ ] in the outhouse i don't care i
don't care
but then on that show the guys want to
find their [ __ ] girl
yeah yeah i want to find a girl that
takes big stinky dumps yeah
honest you know honest about the [ __ ]
steamer she takes
cheryl tell me the truth do you [ __ ] big
or not
you're not a [ __ ] girl you've led me on
this whole season
this whole time i was thinking you're a
[ __ ] girl and you're just not you take
rabbit poops
you're a [ __ ] pellet pincher i can't
believe this it's disgusting
true color's really coming out
yeah so xavier found out that cheryl's a
pellet pincher and he's
not happy like xavier
she's a [ __ ] pillow pitcher dude
straight up though there was a girl in
my dreams
she's got a rabbit butt
i can't wait to produce this show
we need to take all our patreon money
and make fart boy island and [ __ ] girl
island
just a trailer for it yeah yeah
this is [ __ ] girl island man that'd be
so
funny a bunch of models i wanted to do a
follow-up on like
because you know i did like that parody
sketch like a while ago just called like
the island i wanted to do one where
all the dudes are plumbers
i'm also a plumber i'm from the uk
this is like six plumbers one house
what fixing fixing the pipes
i think one of them's a plumber yeah
every toilet every tab is broken
and they come in okay no i'll get that
no no oh
no oh we'll get that
he's from newcastle yeah no
nah the girls are like what if you you
want to lay a little pipe into me
sorry sorry miss we're busy
that's when that's going to do like toby
be like
i would like to play no wrong show sorry
sorry
i would like to lay pipe
damn well you know are you going to
watch that [ __ ]
f1 no no i might get high and
i can't i get you might get high on what
like it might be one of those things
where i watch it and i wake up the next
day and go what
what did we watch yeah might be one of
those for me i could really get mad
i get mad because how much they rip love
island it's just
shameless it's every show now
same style and love island like has such
a [ __ ] unique style like the way that
they shot that from the get-go
sucks with that you know the cinema
cameras you get the ultra slow-mo
all that [ __ ] reality tv was filmed with
[ __ ] gopros before yeah brother style
yeah it's the camera quality [ __ ] and
then love island came around was like no
we're gonna produce a [ __ ] out of this
yep and now every single show is doing
that and it's all the same format
they're just trying to find
their spin on it to make it like
somewhat unique and it's not
it just stinks all of it
yeah especially especially [ __ ] girl
island